Житловий будинок без даху - мовчазне
нагадування про війну на Сході Україні.
Тут мешкають п’ятеро дітей зі своїми батьками.
Моторошна і небезпечна домівка.
Це селище розташоване за менш як
кілометр від лінії розмежування.
Вийти надвір побавитися надто ризиковано.
Можна підірватися на нерозірваному снаряді або міні.
Та й обстріли - попри багаторазове оголошення
перемир’я - відбуваються мало не щодня.
Діти живуть недитячими турботами.
Я найстарша серед дітей.
Коли стріляють, я беру їх і веду в маленьку кімнату.
Тому що вона найбільш безпечна.
Це - діти вже майже забутої війни.
Багато з них мають психологічні травми, з якими
часто-густо залишаються наодинці.
Вони підсвідомо намагаються витіснити з голови
страх і жити нормальним життям.
Соня тут з Іллюшою сідають.
А я ось тут скраю, щоб вони не впали.
Іноді ми сюди кладемо ковдру і подушку, і
Аля ось так лягає і спить.
Бойові дії, безумовно, впливають на психіку
будь-якої людини, навіть дорослої.
А дитина ще більше піддається цьому.
Діти можуть почати заїкатися.
Тобто ми бачимо негативні прояви на рівні тіла.
Водопостачання не функціонує.
Діти змушені допомагати дорослим возити воду
з криниці з іншого кінця села.
У нас п’ятеро дітей, яких потрібно годувати, взувати, одягати.
А ще й травма після всіх цих бойових дій,
після цієї стрілянини, бомбардувань.
Право на безхмарне дитинство - цього у п’яти
дітей родини Засядько, на жаль, нема.
Вони - ті, про чиє майбутнє за переговорними
столами, здається, забувають.
Діти війни.